انه يوم الاحتفال بنصر عربي اخر اسود
الاطلس يفوزون على بلجيكا البلد المرشح
لنايل كاس العالم لكن قبل ان يتوقف عند
الفوز نتوقف عند الصوره الصوره التي تحكي
القصه الاجمل نتحدث عن اشرف حكيمي ووالدته
وعلى المدرجات وبعد الفوز على بلجيكا اعطى
اللاعب حكيمي قميصه لوالدته لتعود مجددا
تصريحاته حول اسرته ليس هناك ما يدفعون
بالخجل باسرته فوالدي كان بائعا متجولا
ووالدتك خادمه بيوت وبين الحكمه والوفاء
اليكم اجواء الانتصار المغربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوم جديد من ايام العرب الموندياليه
ابطاله اسود الاطلس الذين تفوقوا على
بلجيكا المرشحه بقوه لحس لقب بطل العالم
رجال المدرب ولدركات كانوا على قدرته
توقعات جار والمنتخب البلجيكي وتفوق عليه
في مرضا مجريات اللي قال يحسموا النتيجه
بهدفين ك لا ايام على موعد مع فرحه سعوديه
بانتصار تاريخيه على الارجنتين واليوم
الفرحه مغربيه انتظر ان تكتمل هذه الفرحه
بالتاهل للدور القادم تاهل اصبح ممكنا
وبسيناريوهات متعدده نتمنى جميعا للمنتخب
المغربي ان ينجح في تحقيق احدها ليكون احد
فرسان الدور السادس عشر لمونديال 2022
للمزيد عن تطورات المونديال مع كلام ميسي
[تصفيق]
على المنتخب البلجيكي في مونديال قطر
المغرب سجل فوزه الثالث في تاريخ مشاركه
في كاس العالم حيث فاز على البرتغال في
المونديال الارجنتين وانتصر على اسكتلندا
في مونديال فرنسا لاول مره في تاريخ العرب
يسجل الان في مباراه واحده في كاس العالم
بعد هدفي عبد الصمد صبري وزكريا ابو خليل
القلب طيب لاسود الاطلس الذين حافظوا على
شباكهم نظيفه في مبارتين متتاليتين اول
مره
تتصدر المغرب مجموعته وتاهلا للدوري
الثاني اما المنتخب البلجيكي فكانت خسارته
مع المغرب ثاني خساره له من المنتخبات
العربيه بعد خساره الاولى امام المنتخب
السعودي في مونديال الولايات المتحده